foreign
welcome to LED live it's a show where we
use the Light of Christ to expose the
darkness found in media and our culture
today and today I'd like to welcome
Heidi and Eva here today thank you so
much for joining us on the show you know
none of us here are financial advisors
but you know although we're not of this
world we're living in this world and
money is one of the things that make the
world go around and so thank you both
for for being on the show can you tell
us a little bit about what you do and
the company that you run okay sure yes
thank you so much for having us
um so I'm an attorney I'm a New York
lawyer and I've been licensed in New
York for since 1998 and so I practiced
actively in New York for 20 years until
2016 when I left the practice of law to
go full time into trading the financial
markets and I trade currencies I trade
on the spot Market I trade currency
Futures as well as equity and commodity
features as well okay so because I trade
currencies I'm always monitoring what
the central banks are doing and the
statements they put out there and what
their activity is because it matters you
know what the dollar does impacts all
the other currencies of the world and
vice versa it does the Yen the Euro and
everything else so I've been watching
what the central banks are doing and
since the pandemic they've been very
active toward developing a central bank
digital currency that's right so and
um I have my own conversion story that
kind of ties into this too because I was
raised Adventist I left the church in
college just drifted away during college
not keeping Sabbath not going to church
and then I was out of the church for
about 31 32 years and I was brought back
in during the pandemic when I saw
because you know I went to law school I
practiced law for these decades and I
saw the Constitution being thrown out
the window and that concerned me and I
saw the potential for the Revelation
prophecies to start playing out wow and
they're playing out in the big way and
the pieces are being moved into place to
cause the type of financial repression
that needs to happen for Revelation 13
17 to be true that no man may buy or
sell save that he had the mark of the
beast or the number or his name
so that's what started me on this that's
number one what brought me back to the
church and I when I saw these things
happening when I saw uh there was a
particular business in New Jersey that
fought the lockdowns and determined to
stay open and were suffered with fines
every day from Governor Murphy in the
state of New Jersey they fought them
they went toe-to-toe of them they're
like we are not going to be ruled by you
know a tyrannical Governor we're going
to stay open we use responsible
practices and we're not closing and they
were fined they were the government the
governor and the state of New Jersey
really persecuted them and tried to make
an example of them and in while the
matter was in litigation and in
controversy that the state seized their
funds seize their bank account they woke
up to a bank account of zero mercy and
it was their entire legal defense fund
over a hundred and seventy thousand
dollars this was attila's gym in Belmar
New Jersey in that case they were on
Tucker Carlson a few times so it was
pretty high profile yeah today was
sentencing day for a South Jersey gym
owner Ian Smith was sentenced to one
year probation for contempt of court
Smith who owns the attilis gym in Belmar
defied covid-19 shutdown orders last
year issued by Governor Murphy he took
the doors off the gym entrance so police
could not lock them and I saw it on
Tucker Carlson and I followed their case
and I was I was just it really struck me
once their funds were seized because I
realized if they could do this to a
small gym in New Jersey
they could persecute Christians around
the world the same way imagine oh you
know waking up to a bank balance of zero
exactly because we're worshiping on the
wrong day I refund yourself right
something like that yeah but it's
interesting the financial realm and
prophecies would put you back into the
church and there's a mixed opinion of
people within the Church of whether you
should engage in the stock market or not
or if you you know Mark of the Beast and
all that kind of things you could really
get into a rabbit hole but so I'm really
interested in what you have to share
today also detailing the connection
because people may not understand that
or may not even know what Revelation 13
is all about but before we get into that
I want to hear Heidi and what you do and
how this connects sure so well we're
sisters
and so it she Eva's part of our
organization called the wisdom Pearl and
so at the wisdom Pearl we're providing
biblical education and we organize
conferences actually public conferences
called the battle for your frontal lobe
because that's really what it's about
right absolutely it all comes down to
Satan doesn't care how he gets you he
doesn't care if the Mark is in the hand
or in the forehead right right but we
know the Seal of God is only in the
forehead that's right so the battle is
for your frontal lobe our first
conference was called fear not fear God
because you know the pandemic instilled
so much fear into people whether it was
medical agencies or government agencies
or them combined people were just
fearful
and we wanted to talk about some of the
current topics in society that are
causing people fear and give them a
Biblical perspective because that's what
it comes down to what does God's word
say about these things that are
happening in society and so Eva was one
of our speakers and she spoke her topic
was called hope during times of trouble
and so she spoke introducing this topic
of cbdc's and how it connects to
Revelation
1317 and we had several other speakers
as well and all the videos are available
on YouTube if the audience wants to
check them out they can go to YouTube
and search the wisdom Pearl and they can
go to our website the
wisdompearl.org and find out more about
the other topics that we're going to be
discussing for example we have an
upcoming conference and this that's also
the battle for your frontal lobe series
The subtitle of the next one is called
science versus science true science
versus fake science
and so you know we want to give a
Biblical perspective on the things that
are happening around us in society and
Eva's Been instrumental in that in our
organization with us and so it's a
privilege you know for her to be you
know reconnected with God and for us to
be able to work together that is a big
blessing because it's a not just a
family business it's a family ministry
ministering to people as a family that's
wonderful okay and all the links that
Heidi just mentioned will be in the
description below so take us to the
topic yeah so uh Central Bank digital
currencies
um those are uh so you know basically
cryptocurrency
that is decentralized for the most part
as long as this there are many
stakeholders it's a decentralized okay
so they might be a variety of people
watching so crypto like if you would
explain it in a sentence or two what
what's cryptocurrency crypto is a
digital currency that is designed to be
decentralized uh users can use it
without being controlled as to how you
can spend it so it's kind of like I look
at cryptocurrency as more or less a
freedom currency and the different
cryptocurrencies have different aspects
to them
um but well to Anchor someone if you
were to compare it to let's say our US
dollar here what is the difference is
like why would someone gravitate towards
crypto versus using the US dollar
uh I guess they would because it's
digital money and it uh May or it may
not it will not be valued typically like
like the dollar would like people are
worried about the valuation of the
dollar and losing uh buying power uh
cryptocurrencies uh they're they're
subject to their own Market as to their
valuation okay so people would invest in
or use cryptocurrencies because they may
think they have an edge over the dollar
in buying and selling and they can do so
also most uh many of the transactions
um can be done peer-to-peer or you know
with different retailers that accept
cryptocurrency
um so people like to do that they can be
done quickly efficiently digital
currency it's instant you know usually
typically there isn't much of a wait
time
um so it's people like that who are
technically minded and and want that
kind of ease of transaction okay the
limitation is it's not accepted
everywhere yeah that's the limitation
isn't it although during the pandemic it
skyrocketed or should it be the
companies that are accepting it
skyrocketed yes especially Bitcoin which
is the major cryptocurrency that people
are familiar with if they're familiar
with any uh people use Bitcoin it's
accepted uh around almost around the
world
um maybe not with every retailer but
there's certainly countries like Nigeria
where their population 50 of their
transactions use Bitcoin wow I don't
know they're very dependent on bitcoin
because Nigeria is one of the countries
that's Implement implemented a cbdc and
they've been very authoritative in
trying to enforce adoption and use of
their cbdc the e-nira how do you spend
it is it on a card your phone
cryptocurrency is typically stored
digitally so it would be stored either
in an online wallet which is not as
secure as like a hard wallet like a USB
drive you know a special it's not just
any USB drive it's a wallet that's
secure with you know seed words and such
I encrypted and everything like that so
that's cryptocurrency but cbdc is the
exact opposite of that so when you think
of cbdc it is fully traceable fully
programmable and centralized with one
Authority your government or your
government Central Bank and that one
Authority will program the rules and
regulations as to how you can use that
currency wow and of course they're going
to see every transaction and so what
they deem is moral or immoral you know I
I see all this going hand in hand with
the China Morelia what was it the social
credit score yes so it's like oh you
were buying a Bible that's that's hate
speech cut your yeah cut your currency
off yes or you were out in China for
instance you could be out in a square
where there's a protest going on and
that will you know be deducted from your
social credit score and penalize you
from being able to take out a loan or
you know something like that and
financially they impose restrictions on
people who are not doing or doing
unfavorable things from the government's
point of view well even as as close as
Canada there's a trucking protest and
people were they were like not from that
yeah they're like well we're gonna we're
gonna carry gas to the truckers and
those people who were just simply giving
truckers gasoline had their Banks cut
off exactly exactly we're getting so
close to this like the controlling of
buying and selling exactly and that
control is more uh efficiently exercised
by the government with a cbdc with the
Central Bank digital currency because
the Central Bank owns the currency they
trace everything's fully traceable fully
programmed by your government your
central bank and so it can be programmed
to not work as to buying certain Goods
or certain items that the government
wouldn't want you to buy or it can also
the government could limit your spending
power they could freeze your spending
power they could freeze your funds and
they could adjust your balances with a
cbdc
that's already been seen with the
Brazilian uh cbdc a developer spoke out
against that and said there's a feature
in the cbdc in the code that permits the
government to freeze your funds and
adjust your balance and they're pretty
much at the top of the food chain like
there's no one holding the government
accountable exactly there's no
regulation for them who's going to stop
your government right yeah boy I mean
what we've been using all this time
we've been using Bank digital currency
when we use our credit cards and our
debit cards and everything if you don't
like the bank you're working with you
can go down the street to another bank
and work with them well if the
government is your bank where are you
going to go when they limit your
spending power or they freeze your funds
and already they've got us on a system
where you can't function without a bank
I mean I I went as long as I could
without a bank and then you start
working for employers that say oh it's
it's digital payment you have to have a
bank and then yeah you're really stuck
in the loop
um so would you tell someone would you
advise well you're not a financial
advisor but if someone were to ask you
would you advise against going with that
kind of digital Bank
is this something that we can
stay away from as long as possible or
you see like Hey we're probably all
gonna get in at some point while we have
choices we should exercise those choices
and of course I'm not a financial
advisor and I cannot give Financial
advice
um we can all make choices and right now
where things exist in the United States
is we don't have a cbdc yet the New York
Hub of the Federal Reserve is their
Innovation Hub is working on a cbdc has
been working on a cbdc for some time but
what we do have which was started in
July is fed now fed now is an infant an
instant payment infrastructure an
instant payment service that allows
Banks and businesses to transfer money
efficiently through the Federal Reserve
and allow instant payments for their
customers so uh last I checked they were
about there were over 50 organizations
who were certified to participate in fed
now you can go to the fednow website and
look at the list of organizations that
are listed to and certified participate
so that's a number of major Banks major
credit unions banking institutions
service providers liquidity providers
uh and they can there there's a list of
them that are certified to use it so
that means that every transaction goes
through the Federal Reserve and they can
see all the transactions that are
happening and fully traceable and Jerome
Powell actually said in September of
2022 when he was asked about a U.S cbdc
what the aspects would be he named four
aspects one would be it would be
intermediated meaning it would be
Federal Reserve working through the
banks to the customers
second it would be privacy protected
third it would not be anonymous it would
be tied to a digital ID wow so they
could see exactly what transactions
you're making if they wanted to limit
the sale of guns they could program the
currency not to work to purchase guns
if they combined it with a social credit
score or a climate change you know score
or carbon footprint score I can't buy
gas today or you can't buy gas today
or something can't book that airline
ticket because you had too much stake
this month you know or imagine if you
don't get that inoculation that is being
highly recommended or mandated not down
your social credit score a lot
what we just went through a season
Affair and there's still a lot of fair
that is ex that exists today how do you
think the government is going to Market
or entice people to join into this well
there's a number of ways I could do it
they could start with the weakest Among
Us which are uh people who are
financially
um you know weak in debt in debt um who
need uh welfare or Universal basic
income if they wanted to bring in
Universal basic income they could issue
that in Central Bank digital currency if
they wanted to issue uh the treasury is
one of the institutions of course that's
certified to work with fed now and with
this dvdc they could issue cbdc as your
federal tax refund or any payments that
the government would issue under
Medicare Medicaid could just be cbdc
that means your doctors would have to
accept it your grocery store would have
to accept it in the bank if banks you
work with will have to accept it so it
could really go through the entire
economy yeah like that I see that yeah
write a lot of incentives too right like
during the pandemic people got checks
from the government right I mean people
are getting
but imagine if your incentive from the
government is coming in the form of a
cbdc and you have to spend it that way
and then you know imagine that you know
people just get used to that convenience
right and they don't think anything
about it right and so then you know
look at what happened when when they
were really really pushing you know the
coveted inoculations I mean people were
getting you know
free meals a hundred dollar gift cards
and it really was the fear of missing
out oh I won't be able to travel or
maybe I'll lose my job so it doesn't
make sense that's an easy transition of
I want to do this and this is what I
have to do to get there so and that was
paired with incentives yeah right so
imagine if an incentive is being offered
along with this right 500 bonus or what
have you yeah right how does all of this
fit into Revelation 13. what is what's
talked about in Revelation 13. so
Revelation 13 uh talks about the end
times uh the Beast and the mark of the
beast and everything especially
Revelation 13 17 says no man may buy or
sell save they have the mark of the
beast or the number of his name the type
of financial repression that has to
exist for them to force the mark of the
beast for the two Beast powers and you
know the first Beast and the second
beast in Revelation and any Beast Powers
working with them to try to force you to
take the mark of the beast they have to
limit how you can buy or sell and
essential Bank digital currency is a
perfect technology to make that happen
because the government can instantly
program whether or not you can spend
that cbdc
yeah whether or not you would be able to
spend that digital dollar
you know are you did you take all of
your mandated inoculations
um did you comply with the things you
were supposed to comply to or were you
seen at a protest maybe in on January
6th yeah or did you go to the One World
Church on that day that you're supposed
to correct were you attending church on
the prescribed day that's a good point
you bring up about January 6 because
even with all that you're saying and I
understand it it's still hard to
conceptualize because of the mentality
of the people in this particular country
the freedoms that we enjoy
it's hard to imagine that people
wouldn't take things into their own
hands and create their own system
separate from the government or start
bartering or just like there will be
such a Revolt maybe even a civil war
that may take place but prophetically we
know that it's going to happen so right
correct the Bible predicts that this
will happen right now so you said what
can we do earlier we can exercise Choice
while we can exercise choice so if they
do come out with a cbdc hopefully we'll
still for a while have other forms of
payment we can use besides it we can
choose banks that are not working with
fed now yet you know and that can be
done now that can be done now you can
check which bank you're banking with and
check it with the list on the fednow
website and if you're working with a
bank that's certified to participate in
fed now you can leave that bank and go
to the bank down the street who's not
participating with fed now and you can
tell them I'm working with you because
you're not certified you're not a
certified participant in fed now and I
want no part of this and I want no part
of cbdc you might find that the banks
don't even know about this or at least
the bank employees aren't really
included into this in fact that's what
Heidi found yeah yeah we recently uh we
recently formed the wisdom Pearl as a
non-profit and so when we went to open
the bank account I made very sure you
know I looked at the list of areas of
area banks in New York and and on Long
Island and there were only a small
handful of banks that were even an
option that were not participating in
fed now but we found a couple that were
not and we went to them and you know
we're sitting with a bank manager and a
bank representative and
you know I I asked them I said so are
you familiar with you know cbdc's and
you know and that our country is looking
to develop a cbdc and they said no
what's that come again what's that yeah
I said so do you know what fednow is and
they said no and
we had we ended up going to another bank
and at that bank the representative
asked well what brought you in today and
I said what brought us in is the fact
that you're not a registered bank and
fed now and you know we're looking to
bank with a bank that will protect our
rights as long as possible okay I wonder
what the the incentive for the banks to
join into this why are so many banks uh
working with that probably just going
along with the crowd being Progressive
or seeing where things are headed and
wanting to capitalize as much as
possible what would you say to someone
who may walk away with this thinking if
I am either banking with a bank that's
part of fed now or if I join in with
cbdc that I'm joining in with the mark
of the beast
well first of all we want to establish
that a cbdc is not the marker of the
Beast right we know that from studying
the Bible right we know what the mark of
the beast is and it is not a chip it is
not you know a currency it is not
anything like that but as Eva was saying
in Revelation 13 17 one of the very
prominent verses about the repression
that will come to those who are keeping
the Commandments of God and have the
faith of Jesus is a financial repression
right and so the verse clearly says that
no man may buy or sell save or accept
that they have the mark of the beast or
the number of his name and so
you know this is just one of the ways
that they can get people in compliance
or in line so that when laws are passed
for worship on a specific day that is
not God's day right
they will already have these controls in
place and think about today how many
people are just so comfortable and so
convenience oriented right that will
just go along with this and we know that
that's why people will receive the mark
of the beast in their hands action based
it's action-based right so I didn't want
to cut you off but I just want to
establish that we know that this is not
the mark of the beast the mark of the
beast involves worship yes absolutely
yeah you're absolutely right and I'm
glad you jumped in there and the cbdc
would be part of the enforcement
mechanism to try to constrain the user
and force a certain behavior that the
government would like to see it's a
means to an end yes okay yeah and
there's another
um so you can think of Central Bank
digital currency and this is not an
exaggeration it's digital Financial
enslavement that's disguised as money
you participate in it you're giving the
governor government the right to curtail
your freedoms and spending if you do not
have a financial if you do not have the
freedom to conduct whatever Financial
transactions you wish to conduct you're
not free
your Freedom's been taken away from you
and the fact that the the currency is
fully traceable and the government can
see all of your transactions that's a
waiver of your Fourth Amendment right
against unreasonable search and seizure
because right now if the government
wants to see what you're spending on
they're supposed to get a warrant
they're supposed to go to court and get
a warrant and then present that to your
bank and then they can see your
transactions that's the way it's
supposed to work whether or not they go
around that is another story especially
with the January six people I've been
thinking this has been implemented like
small steps for a long time because like
I said now we're in a system where you
can't not have a bank but
even if you were like well I spent I I
always spend cash
are you going to use that you know
grocery store thing that's going to save
you 10 cents well that's linked to your
name so there's always a paper trail
somewhere there is a trail saying oh we
saw that you went to the grocery store
here how I spent cash have you scanned
your little card yes constantly they've
been conditioning us to accept that kind
of lack of privacy check in yeah check
in to save 10 on your meal we got we
know exactly where you've been what
you've been doing yes yeah I mean anyone
who has a smartphone yeah
listening all the time yeah it's
listening to you all the time yeah so
this is just one of the ways that the
government would enforce the type of
behavior that they want to see it is as
we've seen so easy for the world to slip
into a frenzy but as Christians we have
promises in the Bible and the Lord says
you know I haven't given you the spirit
of fear but of power and of love and of
a sound mind so amen what are some steps
that a Christian can take to ensure that
they have a sound mind during a period
where choice is taken away like what can
be done now as we move towards that time
well um like I said you can choose a
bank that's not participating in set fed
now but like I said before I and we can
contact our politicians and let them
know that we do not want this okay so we
can try to put it off as long as
possible we can try to fight and I think
we should fight we should resist we
shouldn't bow down to this type of or
bend over for this type of you know
repression unfortunately during the
pandemic we saw a lot of people just
allow their rights to be taken away from
them out of fear or convenience no you
know that it's happened before in the
name of like after 9 11 after 9 11
people were willing to give up their um
freedoms for security they could do they
would do the same thing here potentially
um so we can try to fight it as much as
possible and I think we should fight it
and we should resist and we shouldn't
give up our freedom so easily because
they're so precious and we we're not
used to this in the United States we're
used to thinking we have freedom right
at least thinking we have freedom and
exercising that freedom and once it's
taken away
We're not gonna be able to get it back
right right well we are we are called to
resist although we know the inevitable
so in resisting we're just making sure
that we align with the correct Choice
especially when it comes to worship that
in preparation as we're resisting in
preparation for that time when choice is
taken away I'll be more specific someone
might listen to the show and say oh I
got a stockpile you know or oh I gotta
have a cash in in my house or what have
you would you say those are practical
things that that should be done oh I
gotta leave all form of city and go out
into the country like those kind of
things has that ever come up
in these conversations that you've been
having as steps towards the inevitable
well that can help and that can uh give
you a little more freedom a little for a
little bit longer but um ultimately we
know that the Bible predicts this is
going to happen and it's going to extend
globally to everyone around the world
even if you're in the country you're
going to be on land where you have to
pay taxes and you're gonna have to pay
taxes eventually in cbdc
um you know according to what we see in
Revelation and how we think see things
moving every major country is working on
a cbdc and the bank of international
settlements did a survey
um and they just released a report of
their survey and it said that 93 I
believe it was 93 of the banks that they
surveyed are working on a cbdc so all
the countries there's a number of
countries that already have it Caribbean
countries and Nigeria with e-nira China
has their pilot program uh the ewon or
the digital one and actually they're
promoting it big time right now the
Asian game started September 23rd and
are running through October 8th and
they're trying to encourage adoption and
use of the E1 with an app trying to get
people to buy their tickets for the
games using the app using the Central
Bank digital currency trying to get
International
users to use the you know the cbdc
issued by the the CCP
you know the Communist Chinese
Bank you know the Bank of China so so
really what this did for you was you
were in a place where you you were
raised in the church you heard these
prophecies but you but I didn't believe
them yeah I didn't believe them
yeah how could this possibly happen we
have a constitution we have a supreme
court we have a Judiciary that's
supposed to guarantee our freedoms how
could this possibly happen and when I
saw the Constitution being thrown out
the window during the pandemic I was
like oh it's on you know
I better start reading my Bible again
and I have to start going to church
again and it's just so it's just so
clear to me how these pieces are falling
into place and people don't realize it
so I'm trying to sound the alarm I'm
trying to make people aware and I'm
trying to encourage people to spread
awareness of this so we can resist it as
for as long as possible but really we
know from The Book of Revelation that
this is eventually going to happen so
the most important thing I think people
should do is to
reinforce the relationship with God and
really build and strengthen their
relationship with God and really don't
skip your morning devotions because
you know you're gonna we're gonna come
to a time we're gonna we're gonna be
totally dependent on God yeah we're not
going to be able to spend our money
where even if you're sitting on a pile
of cash you may not be able to spend it
at some point right so you're gonna be
totally dependent on God you know and
I've heard Pastor Pavel Goya for
instance say recently
um and he's I'm sure he said it before
Jesus is coming soon you know and
um we're going to be that generation
that sees Jesus face to face so do you
want to see do you want him to say to
you
um well done faithful servant or I I
don't know you all right all right you
know you hit the nail on the head in in
that response so the three that I got
from your the three ways to prepare that
I got from your answer was one get
involved right uh in terms of the the
policies happening in your local
government be aware of what's happening
and then develop sorry and bring
awareness spread that awareness yeah
it's got to be a Watchman right yeah and
then have that relationship with God
those three combined which also
intertwine because you can't be involved
if you're not aware and then how can you
get involved as a Christian responsibly
unless you have that relationship with
God so all three uh combined together
will bring that that peace of mind
during this time and also have us be a
light to those who may not know or who
might be part of that frenzy so that was
actually yes absolutely absolutely it's
a great time for people to detach from
their belongings yeah that's you know
psychologically even right because we
many many people in all around us in our
culture in our communities in our
country we could never imagine the time
when every Earthly support will be cut
off yeah
but that's right around the corner and
so you know out of convenience out of
luxury out of whatever it might be
people are dependent on their
smartphones their Smart TVs their Smart
Homes all their smart devices and we've
become just so conditioned and
accustomed to our belongings and our
devices and what we have and what we
really need to have As Eva said is a
relationship with our Savior Jesus
Christ or so fixated on a problem or
hypothetical and not seeing the solution
right in front of you correct like to
make it personal for me it was a very
hard transition for me to move out of
New York to Tennessee and one of the
main reasons was like there's like no
public there's not even sidewalks in my
area like to go from place to place I
would need a car yeah but I have a car
so it's okay for me personally right so
I have a car so why am I worried about
public transport why am I so fixated
that there's no sidewalks when that
doesn't necessarily apply to me as an
individual and for the individual that
it may apply to they don't have a car
well again I have a car so I could be of
help to that person so taking that
example and applying it broadly of like
sure you might be so fixated on this
issue but the solution is right here and
we should be praising God for the
solution in our lives yes praise God so
the other thing
um that I've been reporting on on my sub
stack my sub stack is revelation 13 17
cbdcwatch.substack.com and you can find
it there and I publish all kinds of news
coming out with respect to cbdc's and
how close we are along with Bible verses
and encouraging people to depend on God
and and you know seek God and really for
everything for all of your friends
and it helps support her Ministry it
does help support my Ministry yes so one
of the things I've reported on also is
so it's not bad enough that they want to
control your money with cbdc they also
want to control all your assets so the
bank of international settlements is the
central bank that the central banks go
to and they um they facilitate
cross-border settlements and such like
that and so they issued their annual
report and they issued one chapter of
their annual report in June 20 2023 and
what they laid out was a plan for
tokenization of all privately held
property on a global unified Ledger RC
so the token would be coded with smart
contracts and rules and regulations as
how the the asset can be owned how it
can be transferred if it can be
transferred if you can retain ownership
of your asset and also The Ledger the
unified Ledger would have a data
environment that would incorporate data
from Real World events that could
potentially impact the transferability
of your asset
you'll own nothing and be happy exactly
exactly that's exactly how they would
accomplish that you might think you own
something but guess who controls it yeah
not you
so I encourage people to you know stop
by my sub stack Revelation 13 17
cbdcwatch.substack.com and I try to
share these things and try to share some
encouragement and
um perhaps you know some words of wisdom
if I can awesome thank you for that
reason from the Bible okay so people
can't people part of that list can reach
out to you for maybe uh with specific
questions or anything like that yes yes
of course post comments post questions I
answer all comments and questions and
awesome fantastic we'll have that
resource in the in the links below and
Heidi if someone has a question about
what you're involved and how can they
reach you sure they can reach us at the
wisdompearl.org and uh we encourage
people to come and you check out our
website check out our upcoming
conferences can they register on the
website they sure can they can buy their
tickets online and
um our next conference people will not
want to miss especially if they care
about some of these really hot topics in
society today a such as creation versus
Evolution if they care about the gender
dysphoria that's going on in our schools
and if they care about the climate
change agenda that is uh right right
before us I think if they go to this
they're going to get equipped with how
to respond to some of those they sure
will you know you might believe
something but can you defend your
beliefs that's something that I love
about apologetics yeah
yeah
thank you Heidi thank you for having us
and thank you Eva thank you so much
appreciate both of you well if you were
blessed by our conversation today I I
hope that you would like this video and
share it to those around you also
subscribe if you're new here we're here
every Friday on LED live
um also if you're interested in what
little light Studios has going on you
can go to our website
littlelightstudios.tv and if you'd like
to support us financially you can do so
through that same website or you can go
to patreon.com Little Light Studios we
have a new Venture going on right now
with little light kids you can subscribe
to that YouTube channel it's content all
for kids the link to that will be in the
description below thank you so much for
watching we hope you have a blessed
weekend and we'll see you next week on
LED live bye-bye then very soon we will
be beyond the god of the Bible there are
11 genders that The Vedic tradition
recognizes so for all those genders
understand Native Americans have
recognized five genders this dual gender
is one of the conspiracy against the
humanity when the Kundalini your
Kundalini is awakened
fundamentally first thing will happen is
you are identity about you
for the purpose for which you the body
will become clear to you can I ask how
many genders you think there are
over 10 is it a social construct would
you say yeah
two gender genders or
no like whatever you feel it's I think
it's really fluid right now you know
it's getting more and more acceptable to
be whoever you want to be so non-trivial
it has the potential of a civilizational
destruction in the short term the
problem with AI is that it might control
your brain through words
and I
I'm with us for thousands of years
um just think of the Bible and just
think of the Bible
registered to our science versus science
conference to find Hope in the science
that complies with the gospel
and this conferences was inspired from a
quote published in 1890. I have been
warned that henceforth we shall have a
constant contest
science so-called and religion will be
placed in opposition to each other
because finite men do not comprehend the
power and greatness of God
manuscript 16 1890
talks from our speakers will address
Evolution versus creationism
[Music]
gender dysphoria
climate change agenda
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to show
kindness to the world
foreign
to do something that lets someone know
you're thinking of them
every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in return
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to notice
someone in need and to go out of your
way to help them
every day is an opportunity
to do one small thing
to show someone you care
to make the world a better place
[Music]